Okay,
so we're actually going to take a step
back.
Historically,
doctor both Carl Rogers last time as a
phenomenologist,
so we started our brief foray into the
ideas behind phenomenology,
but now we're going to go back in time
and VIP and we're going to talk about
the end of the 19th century and we're
going to discuss Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky and character guard in some
detail and the reason we're going to do
that is because those three men,
I,
I would say more than anyone else in the
19th century,
laid the groundwork not only for what
would become psychoanalysis and then
later personality psychology and
clinical psychology,
but they also describe the broader
social,
political and cultural situation that
modern people find themselves in now and
their thought is exceedingly
sophisticated and it's really worth
grasping.
Because if you can get it,
you know we're going through these
personality theories one of the time and
we're making going to make forays into
biology and neuro psychology.
You need a structure underneath that.
You need to understand a structure
that's underneath all of that to slot
everything into.
Because that way you can understand it
in more detail and so partly because
ideas develop historically and also as
an idea,
as a seed and the seed,
other plants grow and so forth and the
plant grows and so forth and branches
off.
If you can get back down to the origin
point,
then you can often understand the entire
structure more straightforwardly and
also these three men are so brilliant
that it's a joy to encounter their
thinking even though it's very,
very subversive.
Seriously diverse.
So we're gonna start with this diagram
which you will remember.
So okay.
You're so think about this from the pit
of perspective,
like we made the point that as the child
puts itself,
let's say together,
it starts by practicing micro routines,
micro molder,
routines,
and those are accompanied by perceptual
frameworks and also they're incorporated
into a motivational value system because
they're motivated actions and then the
child practices sequencing.
Those micro personalities will say
together to make ever more and more
complex and ever more and more
integrated macro personalities.
And so that's basically what this
diagram describes.
We were looking at it from an adult
perspective.
So you know if you're going to be a good
person,
you can decompose being a good person
into sub of being a good person and you
can decode it,
so being a good person is an abstract
ideal,
but as you move closer and closer to the
point where the goodness is manifested
in action,
you move closer and closer to actual
movements in the world and so the
abstract category good person is
actually made out of.
You can think about it as a very complex
melody of motor motor actions and
perceptions.
Perception is very tightly linked to
motor action because whenever you
perceive anything,
you're doing it in part by actively
investigating world is partly why your
eyes are moving around all the time and
if you're listening,
you move your head and touch something.
You have to actively investigate it.
So it's always an activity of
exploration.
Now in some ways when you think about
the child piecing,
it's.
It's being together from the bottom up.
You can think about that as a biological
process unfolding.
You know,
and you can take up the child is
crawling and then learning to walk as a
biological process unfolding,
but that's an oversimplification because
human beings exist from day one in a
very,
very social world.
And so what that means is the way that
those behaviors are sub micro
personalities start to organize
themselves is always under the influence
of,
of the society in which they're
embedded.
And so,
you know,
Piaget talked about the child as,
as,
as being,
uh,
as,
as having reflex basic built in reflex
is at birth,
and that,
that,
those reflexes are then elaborated up
into more and more complex structures.
But you can think that even the
elaboration of those basic reflexes,
even right from the beginning,
like there's a routing and sucking
reflex,
which you can,
you can listen from a child by tapping
on the side of it's cheap when it's very
new,
newly born and it'll search to try to
put what's tapping in its mouth.
And that's,
that's a,
that's part of the reflection process.
The built in perceptual motor unit that
allows the child to begin to cycle.
Now the thing is though,
what it suckling isn't a static and
objective entity,
it's a person and part of breastfeeding
is the establishment of a relationship,
a complex relationship,
because it's also not only a feeding
relationship,
it's a caring relationship.
It's a relationship that's based on
tactile interaction.
There can be nervousness associated with
it.
Uh,
and,
and often is,
especially for a new mother,
it's a very complex,
dynamic social act.
And so what that means is that right
from the beginning,
in order for the baby to engage in that
process properly,
it has to allow its initial reflexive
movements to be modified by social
necessity immediately.
So for example,
if a baby is breastfeeding,
it can't bite and you know,
it doesn't have any teeth.
So being isn't necessarily a
catastrophe,
but it's not pleasant.
And so what will happen if the baby
bites the mother is that the mother will
pull away and startle the baby and then
the baby will cry and you know,
the father will be at least startled by
the,
by the error.
And so the baby has to learn to you.
It has to learn to be civilized in some
sense.
Right off the bat.
Now you know when Freud was talking
about the process of socialization,
he tended to concentrate more on toilet
training.
No,
because he thought of that as the first
place were the first major place where
the ID of the child,
which which or which Rogers would regard
as an organismic as the organismic.
A experiential domain is brought under
control of the superego.
Right?
Because of the baby.
Obviously it's fundamental biological
function is to relieve itself,
but that has to come under very,
very strict social control and it's a.
it's a complex form of learning which
basically the acquisition of voluntary
control over what was here too for an
involuntary reflex essentially,
and so that can go well or it can go
badly and it can very well go very
badly.
So I knew a family who had a daughter at
one point and that daughter would only
dedicate in her diaper when she was
three.
So that meant she had full of voluntary
control of her bowel function,
but there was no way she was going to
participate in the social ritual that
surrounded proper toilet.
There was a war going on like a serious
war and that sort of thing happens while
not infrequently.
And of course you remember in the crumb
movie,
the mother,
the boys accusing the mother of giving
them enemas and her of course denying
that any such thing happened,
which was something that made both of
them roll their eyes,
you know,
and they all laughed,
but it's really not particularly
amusing.
So anyways,
my point is is that even at the micro
level,
the manifestation of what we'll call
micro personalities expands and
organizes into an environment that's
conditioned by social expectation.
Okay.
So then then,
and this is something we haven't talked
about before,
one thing you might ask is,
okay,
where does the social expectation come
from?
Now that's a very complex question
because in some sense that's the same
question as that as where does culture
come from?
And that's partly a complex question
because you have to take into account
evolutionary history which provides the
substrata for the development of
culture.
So that would be human biology of take
that into account and then you have to
take human history into account and,
and we're what you don't have to take
into account is not clear,
right?
Because it's very difficult to,
to track the origins of the social
routines that make up the fundamental
social contract.
You know,
we know how to behave properly.
Roughly speaking.
We have a set of expectations and a set
of wants for about the way that other
people are going to behave with regards
to us.
And they returned the favor and everyone
is participating in this and everybody
basically knows,
unless they're very poorly socialized,
you can usually tell that right away.
You know,
kids can tell that because if a three
year old is playing with another three
year old and one of them is poorly
socialized and so maybe has the
behavioral repertoire of a fairly badly
behaved two year old.
The other three year old being socially
sophisticated will say,
will not play with the first one,
so even though they might be perfectly
happy to play for a time with an actual
two year old,
so it doesn't take very long.
It's really about the age of three.
The children are already sophisticated
enough to have embodied the rules that
constitute appropriate cultural behavior
and those rules are there patterns
actually for the exactly rules for the
child because the child couldn't
explicitly state them,
but they can act them out.
Now you remember now,
Piaget talked about this a fair bit,
right?
Because he said that part of the way
that the slightly larger micro
personality say have a two year old are
integrated into the broader social world
is through games that are played with
peers and with older children and the
games are ways that like a game is
fundamentally a negotiated.
It's a negotiated sphere of action and
perception that has a particular goal
and the goal is defined by the players
and the sphere of interaction is defined
by the players.
And so then if you're a good player,
what happens is that you become part of
a higher order structure and the
hierarchy structure is the game.
So if you're playing soccer,
all of a sudden if you're civilized,
what you do is you manifest those
behaviors that are appropriate to play
soccer and you subordinate your
voluntarily subordinate,
your individuality at that point to the
higher order structure of the game.
That's a communal agreement.
So it's a basic social contract.
And so you practice being part of basic
social contracts by playing games.
And you can do that with games that are
in some sense relatively straightforward
and regulated by strict conventions and
articulated rules.
And so that would be like a soccer game
or you can do it in a more complex way
and a less,
a less,
a less structured and less articulated
manner by engaging in dramatic play.
And so what children usually do when
they're doing that is that they'll
gather around a little group and
they'll,
they'll lay out the drama.
So drama would be,
we're going to simulate x,
we're going to simulate a family.
And then everybody is assigned a role
and so you're supposed to act out your
role,
but exactly how you're supposed to act
it out is left open during the games so
you can riff and improvise and basically
what children are doing when they're
doing that is acting out the family and
you know,
because they need to get the family in
their bones.
Because being a parent isn't a set of
ideas about parenting.
It's a set of behaviors.
It's a dance that you learn to have with
your children and with your partner.
And it's very complicated and the rules
go far beyond what you could ever
articulate,
you know,
because you can ask yourself a question
like,
well,
how should you discipline a child?
Well,
first of all,
you can argue about that forever,
but second of all,
you cannot actually elaborate a set of
principles that will guide your behavior
in every situation where a child is
likely to disrupt the social
circumstance.
So you have to be smarter than you can
say in order to be good at doing
something as complicated as disciplining
a child.
Now,
because discipline also means
encouraging,
right?
Because it's part of discipline as well,
you shouldn't do those things,
but another part of it is you should
definitely do more of those things and
so it's the inculcation of a moral code
and a lot of that's done through
nonverbal behavior and through providing
a role model for spontaneous invitation
and all sorts of things that aren't
verbal.
Okay.
Now,
so,
so piaget talked about the game and then
you could take the games become more and
more complex and more and more abstract
and more and more like real life as you
mature until they.
They may be the games transform into
what sociologists would refer to as
roles.
So the role you're playing at the moment
that at least in principle is student
and you know it's a game and it's a game
because it's a fiction in some sense,
you know,
it's a fiction.
It's a dramatic fiction in some sense.
The only reason that it exists as a role
is because society is structured in such
a way that enables.
This too enables you to do what you're
doing and to live at the same time.
So it's not exactly how to outpatient to
the normal,
to the natural world in any sense of the
in any sense of the word,
but it's also,
it's also real life or maybe it's almost
as close to real life as you ever get
because almost everything that modern
people do,
and maybe this is true for a long time
into the past,
his game like in its structure,
so the game's just get more and more and
more.
There's more and more and more
encompassing in some sense.
But you can,
you can almost.
You can almost say that it never comes
to the point where what you're doing is
no longer playing the game.
Now that's a bit of an
oversimplification,
but because there are games and games,
but we won't talk about the games at the
moment.
Okay.
So now you can understand sort of some
of the lower order games and you can
even understand some of the higher order
roles.
Like you,
you could basically articulate in some
sense what it means to be a student.
But if you go up the hierarchy,
you know,
because good person,
a subset of good person could be good
student.
You can kind of articulate what it means
to be a good student,
although you can't fully articulate it,
but if you go at levels above that,
like be a good citizen or be a good
person,
but gets more and more difficult to
fully articulate because of course it's
more and more abstract and in
encompasses more and more territory and
so by the time you're at the top of the
hierarchy,
so to speak,
be a good person.
Well,
it's much.
It's a much more complex phenomena than
you can articulate.
It can't be fully articulated.
Now I want to read you something that
Nisha said.
Now you have to listen to this carefully
because there's some very interesting
things about the way nature writes.
He's writes a for forest,
an need for Islam is a short statement.
Often only a sentence,
but more typically a paragraph.
Next,
very,
very densely packed with ideas and I
think you could say in some sense that
if you read Nietzsche,
the stuff that I'm going to read right
now is from beyond good and evil that
every single sentence has an idea in it
and it's often an original idea and
that's a remarkable accomplishment.
I mean I've often gone through books and
marked.
I usually fold the top of the page over
mark where I think there is an idea
worth keeping.
It's an idea I haven't run into before.
So it's an original idea and I would say
in a typical book I read there's none of
them.
There might be one or two,
but with nature there's probably 20 on a
page and so it makes it,
it,
it's.
He's packed a tremendous amount of
information into a very,
very small space and one of the things
and he tried to do that and there was a
bunch of reasons.
One was his health wasn't very good,
although he was an early stage genius.
He was a full professor in Germany,
I think when he was 22 or 23,
which is impossible because if you don't
become a full professor,
especially 130 years ago,
140 years ago in a German University at
the age of 23,
it just isn't possible,
but he was a spectacular genius,
but his health failed him and so he had
a very difficult time writing and so
what he did was spending an awful lot of
time thinking and a very short period of
time writing.
And so what that meant was that he would
take a tremendous amount of thought,
genius level thought and then compress
it into like a single sentence or a
single paragraph in and he said that he
liked to philosophize with a hammer and
in some sense,
you know now you know about hierarchy
that I just showed you.
You know,
we talked about the idea that if you hit
something disruptive in your life,
that the magnitude of your response is
proportionate to the,
to the elevation of the level.
Right?
It's much more damaging to be accused of
being a bad person.
You know,
seriously,
than it is for someone to complain
about,
you know which side of the plate you
happen to put the forecourt.
So and I think you can say that you can
sort of think of those nested
hierarchies of value as nested
hierarchies of.
They're almost like maps in the sense
there their little units of things,
ways that you know how to maneuver in
the world and not in.
What that means is that as you go up the
hierarchy,
the map is larger and larger and more
comprehensive and so if you blow out
someone's map of which fork to put on
the table,
that's not so bad.
They can just rectify that in no time
flat.
It leaves 99 point nine,
nine percent of their personality and
tech.
But if you fail a crucial exam for it,
for example,
and part of the reason that you're going
to fit your a student is because you
want to go to medical school.
You know that'll blow out like 50 or 60
percent of your personality.
Or at least it'll feel that way.
And that's because what's happening is
that the structure that you use to
regulate the relationship between you
and the world has become damaged at a
high level.
And that invalidates,
like if you're not a student,
if you're not a good student anymore
than all of the sub factors that make up
being a good student might be invalid.
And you know,
you might've put a lot of effort into
being a good student.
And so if all of a sudden you're not
that,
you have to ask yourself,
well,
what exactly am I and where are all the
errors?
And that's a very,
that can be a,
well that's an extraordinary difficult
cognitive problem because you've built
that structure who knows,
you know,
over what period of time it might be 15
years or something like that.
And you'd be practicing building that
structure and it's a huge part of your
identity because someone might say,
well,
what are you even?
And you'd say a student,
you know,
they might say,
what do you do?
But they could easily say,
what are you?
I'm a student.
While if you're not a student at least
in so far as you desire to find student,
then just exactly what are you.
All right.
So nature,
you know,
when he packed a lot of information into
a sentence or a paragraph,
you have to be very careful reading him
and young is like this too because he'll
throw some information if you that's
packed into a paragraph and it'll be the
kind of information that disrupts high
level structures.
You won't even notice it,
but because it's so subversive and he,
he wanted to do that.
It was the name of his.
He had his reasons to do it.
He would say that you have to be broken
down to nothing before you can be
rebuilt.
So it's like a trip to the underworld
thing.
So,
and I suppose in many ways that's what
philosophy is.
You know,
it's,
you don't learn a new principal without
allowing old principles to disappear
because you can't have the new principal
and the old principal at the same time.
So almost always any radical learning
involves the destruction of old habits
and have action and perception.
And that's,
that's a kind of death,
like it's a,
it's a,
it's an abstract death,
you know,
but at that doesn't make it not painful.
And the thing is,
if the abstract is of sufficient
intensity,
it can drive people to suicide because
they regard killing themselves as easier
than making the reparation,
you know,
facing the anxiety and the suffering and
going through the intolerably difficult
task of retooling and they may well
regard that as more emotionally
threatening then death.
And so and that,
that's not that rare,
you know,
I mean,
suicide is rare,
but it's not that rare.
So you know,
and it certainly a behavior that
everyone is.
I suspect everyone here has known
someone who was touched by suicide in
some way,
you know,
it might not be your family member or
even your extended family member,
but the probability that you know,
someone who knows someone who committed
suicide is extremely,
extremely likely.
So Nietzsche is a very dangerous,
dangerous thinker.
I'm the only person I know who kind of
approaches him and not regard as young.
And Yoga is actually less troublesome
because a lot of what does the NSBE
offers is his destruction.
It's intelligent,
brilliant destruction,
but he doesn't really offer a solution.
He's sort of sketches out the
possibilities of a solution and he died
young and then in many ways what
happened was that young picked up where
[inaudible] left off and tried to solve
the problems that need you left
unsolved,
so it was nature,
for example,
in some sense,
along with Dostoevsky who really
definitively announced the death of God
at the end of the 19th century in that
left people in some ways bereft of
belief,
and we're going to talk about why that's
so important in a moment.
What union was doing was trying to.
Well,
he was trying to rescue the farther from
the underworld in the sense he was
trying.
He tried to go back to the religious
traditions that Nietzsche had had
described as fatally anachronistic and
demolished by the claims of science.
He attempted to go back to those
religious traditions and reassess them
from a psychological perspective to pull
back the necessary meaning that was
embedded in them so that people could
reunite with their culture and in
principle not be so prone to
pathological belief systems like
ideology that tend to rush in where
there's a gap.
You know,
a niche has said very clearly and and
Dostoevsky knew this as well by the end
of the 19th century,
is that the death of God would mean that
people would turn on Mohs to
rationalistic ideologies and that would
be murderous.
They knew that was coming and that's an
amazing prediction,
really is amazing prediction.
It just shows you how thoroughly they
understood the structure.
Okay,
so I'm going to read you something by
nature and then we're going to return to
the hierarchy so that you can kind of
understand something deeper about the
way the hierarchy is structured.
Okay?
Now he's talking about philosophical
ideas here and he's actually talking
about articulated ethics.
So one way that you might think about
philosophy is that philosophers or
originate articulated moral principles,
and that is often the way that people
think about especially moral philosophy.
It's like it's the philosophers who come
up with the ideas,
but that isn't what needs you believe.
Here's what he said.
Instead,
separate philosophical ideas are not
anything optional or autonomously
evolving.
They grow up in connection and
relationship with each other.
However,
suddenly an arbitrarily they seem to
appear in the history of thought.
They nevertheless belong just as much to
assist them as the collective members of
the fauna of a continent.
Okay?
So it's a very interesting idea.
So the first idea that he's putting
forward is that you could.
The best way to think about a
philosophical system,
say a philosophical system of ethics is
as if it's different statements are
animals related to one another in an
ecosystem.
So he has a biological metaphor in some
sense,
for,
for the emergence of a philosophical
system.
It's quite an interesting way of
thinking,
of course,
and it makes sense because if a
philosophical system of ethics,
which is a philosophical system that
tells you how and why you should behave
a certain way is about how you should
act and you're a biological being,
then of course,
it only makes sense that the concepts
themselves which are guides to actions,
can logically be considered biological
entities.
They're abstracted biological entities,
but they still have the same nature as
biological entities and that means
according to meet you,
that they're subject to the same rules.
Now,
this is the sort of place where he
foreshadows Freud deeply,
so
nature says
they never little last belong just as
much to assist them as the collective
members of the forerunner of a
continent.
This is be treated in the end by the
circumstance.
However,
unfailingly,
the most diverse philosophers always
fill in,
again,
a definite fundamental schema.
Possible philosophies under an invisible
spell.
They always resolved once more in the
same orbit.
However,
independent of each other,
they may feel themselves with their
critical or systematic wills.
Something within them leads them
something impels them indefinite order.
The one after the other to wit the
innate methodology in relationship of
their ideas,
their thinking is in fact far less a
discovery then direct than a
rerecognition,
a remembering a return and a homecoming
to a far off ancient common household of
the soul out of which these ideas
formerly group philosophizing so far,
it kind of activism of the highest
order.
Okay,
so here,
here's the idea.
There's,
there's two fundamental ideas that are
embedded in this,
which actually neat.
You differentiates.
Alright,
I'm going to read you another section
that illuminates the first one.
It's gradually became clear to me what
every great philosophy up till now has
consisted of namely the confession of
its originator and a species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography and moreover that the
moral or immoral purpose in every
philosophy has constituted the true
vital germ out of which the entire plant
has always grown.
Okay?
So this is a very radical statement.
So because what Nietzsche is saying is
that philosophies,
even when they declare themselves
rational,
are deeply personal and they're also
necessarily embedded within a
motivational structure that is either
pro or anti life,
something like that.
So there's no value free philosophizing.
What there is is the expression of
biologically and culturally conditioned
being which is conditioned by let's say,
the same sort of fundamental forces that
Freud described in the in the in the
biological realm,
and then that's conditioned by the
cultural processes that we just
discussed in relationship to piaget and
then what the philosopher does is
observe that all of those things are
happening.
Allow that to be articulated and confuse
that with his own thought.
That's a brilliant idea.
Now here's a way of thinking about it.
Now,
one of the things Piaget said was that
once children start to play games,
when they're young,
collective games,
you can watch the children play the
collective games like maybe eight kids
are playing marbles or something like
that,
and then you can take the young kids out
of the game and you can ask them what
the rules are.
And what will happen is you'll get a
diverse set of diverse and paradoxical
set of articulated rules.
And what that means is that the children
can play the game when they're in the
game and we're in there in the context
of all the other people because in some
sense the game is embedded in pieces in
all of them and as long as they're all
there,
that all works.
But if you pull the child the way they
don't have the intellectual wherewithal
to do,
describe the patterns of behavior that
make up the game.
And that's only to say that they know
things that they can't say because you
might say,
well,
the game,
the rules of the game come first and
then the game emerges.
But that's wrong.
It's the game comes first.
And only after that do the rules emerge.
And of course there's,
you know,
there's a reciprocal relationship
between them because once the rules are
somewhat articulated,
then the game becomes more structured,
you know,
and,
and the rules can become more structured
and so on.
So the articulation changes the rules.
What niche you is saying is the same
thing applies to societies.
He says like in so far as you can
consider society,
a collective game played by millions of
people over vast spans of time.
It's a game of games in some sense,
and it emerged from the bottom up.
It emerged out of biological impulses
and an interpersonal and social
interactions,
conditioning and shaping everyone's
behavior and perception,
and that happened way before anyone
could articulate what those rules were.
Now you remember when Nisha was writing,
there was no real sense of how old the
earth was or how old the universe was
mean.
People thought even the radical people
thought maybe in terms of hundreds of
thousands of years,
you know,
and now we know that the universe is 14
billion years old and that the earth is
4 billion years old and that life has
been plentiful on the earth for three
point 5 billion years.
You know,
so that the historical context within
which we've originated has expanded by,
by orders of magnitude since the last
19th century.
And so then what you think that means is
that the way that our games have been
organized stretches impossibly back in
time.
Now I already told you I believe the
story about lobster dominance,
higher fees,
right,
so even lobsters that's 400 million
years ago,
lobsters arrayed themselves in a social
space and they regulate each other and
that means the lobsters essentially have
a lobster society and you know,
each lobster has biological
predispositions that are quite
determined.
They're quite a.
The lobster is quite a deterministic
creature,
but nonetheless,
the way that those biological
predispositions manifest themselves is
conditioned and shaped by the social
surrounding.
And so you think,
well,
lobsters start to play games for a
hundred million years ago and you know,
as we've taken the tremendously long
evolutionary journey across that time,
we'd been playing social games the whole
time.
And that means that the way that we
interacted with each other has evolved
and it's even shaped the way our biology
manifests itself because that's how
we'll culture is.
And then out of that,
as we became more capable of
abstraction.
And maybe that's,
you know,
that's something that really took off
probably 7 million years ago with modern
human beings emerging about 150,000
years ago because we separated from the
common ancestor of peep of human beings
in chimpanzees about 7 million years
ago.
You can tell that by doing analysis of
genetic differences.
So the brain expanded very rapidly after
that point and our culture became more
and more conscious and articulated and
complex and larger and more
technological,
you know,
so it became in some ways more dependent
on social norms and less dependent on
deterministic biological
predispositions.
But we've still been doing that for a
very long time.
There's,
there's good evidence that,
um,
you know,
we started using fire about 2 million
years ago.
And uh,
forgive me if I told you this already,
but you know,
if you look at a human being and you
look at a champion z one,
there's a bunch of things you see that
are very different.
Morphologically,
the chimp is much shorter,
much,
much wider and way more powerful.
So like a normal mail chimp is about six
times as strong as the strongest Olympic
athlete.
So don't mess with chimps.
They'll tear you apart,
they're really,
really strong and dangerous.
So.
But the chimp is shaped sort of like
this.
No,
they have a huge gastrointestinal
system,
roughly speaking,
and the reason for that is mostly what
they eat is leaves and leaves,
have no caloric content,
and so they have to eat immense numbers
of leaves and leaves are hard to digest
so they have to chew them like mad.
So the typical chimps sits around eight
hours a day,
chewing,
and then they have this tremendously
long gastrointestinal system because it
takes that long to extract any nutrients
out of out of leaves.
While we circumvented that man,
as soon as we invented fire and fire
allowed us to outsource our digestion
because if you cook most things,
vegetables,
but more importantly meet.
If you cook them,
they become much more bioavailable and,
and it takes much less energy to digest
them.
So that way you can shrink your gut and
grow your brain.
And so that's apparently what we did
because here we are,
you know,
relatively slim at least compared to
chimpanzees and so fire popped up 2
million years ago.
It's a real cultural revolution,
but you know,
that's so old,
that culture revolution,
that content completely reshaped our
bodies.
And so this interplay between biology
and culture,
it's been going on for an unimaginably
long period of time.
And it conditions everything we do.
Now here's a complicated idea.
Okay,
so imagine a wolf pack.
Now.
Wolf pack is a pretty complex,
complicated social group.
It's,
it's a fair bit like a primordial human
group,
which is why dogs have been with us for
25,000
years.
Maybe they were walls that first started
to follow us around.
And scabies,
or more likely,
I think someone went out,
some primordial hunter,
went out hunting,
killed a wolf female,
found the pops and one home for the
children to play with,
you know.
And that was the origin,
the origin of the dog.
I think it was something like that
because dogs are basically,
they're basically genetically identical
with wolves.
Now the thing is is we can get along
with dogs and the reason we can get
lauren with dogs,
because dogs have a social organization,
you could call it a dominance hierarchy.
That's a fair bit like the Human Social
Organization and so you can see that
part of what it means to be human is the
same thing that it means to be a pack
animal like a dog or a pack animal,
like our domesticated horses and cows
for example,
which we can domesticate partly because
there are social.
So some of the structure of our social
organization is the same sort of
structure that an animal dominance
hierarchy has like a chimpanzee
dominance hierarchy for example.
And so we know that chimpanzees and
other primates,
monkeys for example,
are acutely aware of the levels of
hierarchy in their social structure.
And there are,
I think it's vervet monkeys.
This is a very funny experiment.
So imagine that the top vervet monkeys
are like celebrity monkeys,
you know,
and the bottom vervet monkeys are like,
dissolute street people.
And so then you take some pictures of
dissolute street people who are just at
the bottom of the hierarchy and you take
some pictures of celebrities and you
show pictures to a human audience,
and the human audience will look at the
celebrities longer.
Well,
if you take the vervet monkeys and you
take photographs of the top ranking
vervet monkeys and the bottom vervet
monkeys,
and you showed them to vervet monkeys
than the vervet monkeys will look at the
top ranking Verdun Vervet,
monkey photographs more than the bottom
ranking vervet monkey photographs.
So in some sense,
they're transfixed by the individuals
who are higher up in the in the social
order.
And that makes sense,
right?
Because what you should feel,
especially in a fairly aggressive
dominance hierarchy,
what you should feel,
the closer you are to the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy,
the closer what you should feel for
whatever's at the top of the dominance
hierarchy.
That should be.
It should be closer and closer to all.
Now,
when people feel off,
they get chills running up and down
their back,
their neck,
well white.
The reason that happens is because it's
an.
It's an,
it's an activism.
It's a hangover from the time that when
you were threatened by something awe
inspiring,
let's say a snake or a bear or something
like that,
your hair would stand up and the reason
for that is so that you look bigger and
you still see this happening all the
time with cats right to capsule.
Normally cat's face each other this way,
right?
But if they start to fight,
they turned sideways and that so they
each look bigger than they puff up their
fur and their tail and that's to show
the other cat that they're really a lot
bigger than the cat first thought.
Now,
of course they're both doing that so
it's a little bit pointless,
but they're just cat.
So you know you can give them a break,
but the point is is that the pilot will
erect and that's the same thing that
happens.
For example,
when you're listening to very powerful
music and it deeply affects you and you
get chills.
It's like the hair stands up on the back
of your neck and that's the signaling of
all.
Now the reason you should feel odd to
award something that's higher up in the
dominance hierarchy is because that
thing has power like is there.
Well,
there's more than one reason a that
thing has power.
You better be careful of it because it
will put you in your place and fast and
part of the reason the dominance
hierarchy exists is so that everybody
knows their place and they don't have to
be reminded of it by being half killed
on a regular basis.
You know,
so maybe your nine on a scale of one,
one being the top,
maybe your number nine,
it's not so good,
but number nine and not hurting,
there's a lot better than number nine in
lying there bleeding on the ground.
And so what happens with dominance
hierarchies is they usually arrange
themselves in part by power,
but by no means only empower.
Everybody knows where they are and
pretty much everybody stays there and
not even happens over multiple
generations saying in,
in complex primate dominance,
trues statuses heritable so,
and you know that there's not much of a
leap between that.
Inheritable monitor peace among human
beings.
It's a reflection of,
you know,
it's much more complex among human
beings because it's articulated in
structure,
but it's the same basic thing.
Now.
Niches point was so now imagine in that.
Now here's another problem.
So imagine that,
okay,
so you've got a garment,
it's art and it's fairly stable and one
of the things you want to do is climb to
the top of the dominant Turkey.
And the reason you want to do that,
there's all sorts of reasons.
High quality mates,
that's the primary reason that's
particular true in humans.
If you're male,
because males are much more differential
reproducers that females,
which means a lot of males fail to
reproduce completely and some reproduce
a lot.
Whereas the typical woman reproduces at
least some.
So that means competition is more
intense among men.
And that's part of the reason why
dominance hierarchies tend to be tilted
towards male power because competition
means more to them.
The outcome is more crucial.
So now part of what happens is that as
people compete within the dominance
hierarchy,
what they're doing is to try to figure
out who it is that is fit to be on top.
Now you might think that that's a matter
of power,
you know,
in fact,
your basic social lefty,
social constructionists would have you
believe that that was all there is to
it,
is that the whole dominance hierarchy is
nothing but a power system.
And the people on top are there because
they have power and what's there is
power.
And by that they mean the ability to
enforce their will on other people.
Well,
that's a,
that's a dopey theory.
And the reason for that is,
is that if unit dimensional,
you know,
we,
that people are multifaceted,
there's no single motivation.
That's king.
You know,
for Freud it was sex and aggression and
like if you're going to come up with a
couple of potent candidates,
those are two.
But there's lots of other ones.
People are playful and play as a primary
biological circuit.
You know,
we suffer,
we're hungry,
we're thirsty,
we're affiliative.
Like there's a lot of biological
necessity driving the makeup of our
personalities and there are biological
subpersonalities into arbitrarily call
one of them.
The source of something as complex as
social organization is,
it's a.
it's,
it's a,
it's a false form of monotheism.
It's a crazy idea and it's the kind of
idea that only people who really don't
like to think would have.
Because once you come up with that idea,
it's all power.
You don't have to think anymore.
Someone can say to you,
well,
why is complex phenomena x the way it
is?
Why is the economy arranged the way it
Well,
it's so that the people at the top can
maintain their power.
Well,
yeah,
sure,
but maybe that accounts for 10 percent
of the reason it doesn't get close to
100 percent.
There's lots of reasons why hierarchies
are structured the way they are,
and sheer physical force is one of them,
but it's.
It's unstable.
So.
So Frans de Waal,
who was watching chimps organize their
dominance hierarchies in the zoo in
Holland,
noted quite quickly that it was fairly
typical or at least possible for the
meanest,
ugliest,
strongest mail chimp to be the dominant
guide.
Sometimes it was the chip who learned to
pick up a garbage cameron who act the
hell out of it with the stick because
that intimidated his enemies,
you know,
so it's a bit of creativity,
creativity there,
but what,
but what they found was that the stable
hierarchies were never run by barbarian
chimp dictators.
And the reason for that was that
coalitions of other males would take
them out because you know,
you think,
well,
if you're,
if you're one of antisocial aggressive
male in endure tough,
it's like,
okay,
you're tough.
But three lesser friendlier males who
are bound together in a friendship pack,
which chimpanzees form quite intensely.
It's like as soon as that guy turns his
back or has a bad day or gets hurt,
they're going to jump in there and tear
him to pieces.
And that's exactly what happened.
So what below found was that the stabler
chimpanzee dominance hierarchies were
run usually by males who were
affiliative and gregarious who
remembered their social obligation.
So that meant with with regards to their
friendship network and who were also
very good to the females and the infants
in the truth,
even if they weren't his.
And the idea there is that power is an
unstable basis for the maintenance of a
dominance hierarchy across time.
Because in some sense,
even among the chips,
you have to have the consent of the
governed because you'll get a revolution
otherwise.
And so you know you're going to get a
revolution if you put people in or
animals in the situation where they have
nothing to lose.
And so what that means is there are
constraints on how you can act well.
You try to move up the dominance
hierarchy system because if you're too
aggressive and selfish and you're not
grooming anyone else and you're not
communicating with the other creatures
in the truth,
they're going to gang up on you and take
you down.
And so if you're going to maneuver your
way up the true,
you have to be do it in a manner that
civilized enough so that you don't get
every one against you.
And so what it means is that to maneuver
up a power hierarchy,
especially a complex power art
heartbeat,
you have to be a lot more than powerful.
So,
okay,
now,
so now we've got this idea that there
are principles governing the movement of
peep,
of creatures up a dominance even among
the animals,
and one of the defining characteristics
of the that,
that one of the characteristics that
necessity makes the limit,
that process is that overtime the truth
can't let anybody climb the dominance
hierarchy who will destabilize the whole
dominance heart.
Because then that's it.
Game over.
So at the very least,
you have to learn how to climb up the
hierarchy so that you don't destabilize
it while you climb,
because otherwise you get to the top and
there's nothing left.
Well,
and in animals know this,
they know this instinctively.
So for example,
when wolves go at it first,
they puff up and they'd grow with each
other and they put up their shoulders
and like they get more and more
aggressive until attack is imminent and
often one of them will back off with
there's no fighting,
no one gets damaged.
And,
and so that's the typical situation.
It's like one says,
yeah,
okay,
you know,
I'm,
I'm out of here.
And God only knows why that is.
Often I suspect the wolf with the higher
serotonin level winds because it has
less negative emotion.
And Sarah Donin levels go up as you move
up the dominance art now.
And then they'll go into,
you know,
they'll actually have a fight,
but the fight usually doesn't last very
long.
And then the loser will roll over,
throw itch,
show its throat to the winter,
which is quite a behavior because wolves
tear the throats out of,
of,
of their prey.
And the top woeful back off.
And you know,
you think about,
that's unbelievably sophisticated
morality.
You know there there's echos in there of
the New Testament injunction to love
your enemy because that's exactly what
the wolf is doing and you know it
doesn't know this because it can't
articulate the rule,
but what it's doing is acting as if even
the thing that attacked you is valuable
in its own right.
If it's part of your truth and you know,
you can see there the,
the,
the ancient biological origins of the
idea of the,
you know,
of the,
of the equality and value of each
individual.
So these things have deep,
deep,
deep roots.
They're not arbitrary,
they're not arbitrary and no one
invented them.
And that's exactly what Nietzsche is
saying here.
To understand how the abstruse
metaphysical assertions of a philosopher
have been arrived at,
it is always well.
And why is to first ask oneself what
morality do they or does he aim at?
Accordingly?
I do not believe that an impulse to
knowledge is the father of philosophy,
but that another impulse here as
elsewhere has only made use of knowledge
and mistaken knowledge as an instrument.
But whoever considers the fundamental
impulses of man with a view to
determining how far they may have here
acted as inspiring Jeannie or as demons
will find that they have all practiced
philosophy at one time or another and
that each of them would have only been
to glad to look upon itself as the
ultimate end of existence and the
legitimate lord of over all of the other
impulses.
So what is he saying there?
Well,
you know,
nature makes this explicit in passages
that are related to this one.
He viewed the human being as a
collection of sub souls and the souls
were grounded in their existence and in
biological underpinnings.
And that was the case for every human
being in that made us roughly similar.
It certainly made our groups roughly
similar.
And so these,
each of these biological subsystems
conceptualized as a sub soul was
something that had its own viewpoint,
has its own rules,
had its own games,
and they would,
they jockey for precedence.
Now you know that because sometimes
you're sitting there reading and you're
trying to concentrate on a higher order
goal,
like completing your classes.
And you know,
some biologically determined subsystem
pops up and says,
you know,
this would be an excellent time to go
have a coffee,
you know,
and you might do everything you can to
not allow that thing to take over,
but often it does.
And so,
and often that's despite what you think
you might actually want to do.
And then later you're all upset about it
because you've procrastinated yet again.
But you know,
nature view the psyche as a place you
could almost think of yourself as a set
of apps.
It's like your brain is a set of animals
and the animals are all dependent on one
another,
but each animal needs to be boss from
time to time.
And each animal wants to be boss more
often than it should be.
And then you know,
the higher order critical systems are
there to figure out how to sequence all
of these other animals so that they all
get what they need without interfering
with each other across large spans of
time in the presence of many other
people in a manner that's sustaining.
So it's very,
very complicated.
Okay.
Now,
so let's go back to the hierarchy so you
have the hierarchy and overtime.
Now remember,
this hierarchy stays there for a very
long period of time and remember as well
that the people who climbed to the top
of the hierarchy are much more likely to
leave offspring than the people who
don't.
And so then what that means is that the
hierarchy in part is one of the primary
selection forces operating on humanity
and what that means is that we evolve
towards the thing that can most
successfully climbed the dominance
heart.
And so that means that we evolve towards
the thing that has the best probability
of ruling properly and that that's not
just cultural.
It's cultural because it's the continual
interplay between cultural and biology.
Going back,
we'll save 400 million years or more.
Okay,
now,
but it's even more complicated than
that.
And,
and this is one of the things that you
have to understand if you really want to
understand what niche of meant by the
death of God.
So because that's his most famous
pronouncement,
God is dead and we have killed them and
we'll never find enough water to wash
away the blood now.
So he wasn't announcing that in triumph.
He was announcing it in terror.
Okay,
now imagine this.
So as human society becomes more complex
and as our brains become larger and
larger so that we can track larger
social organizations and we can organize
more complex communities.
What happens is that here to for
isolated tribes of people come together
and then they have to engage in conflict
and negotiation and partly what they're
in conflict about is what is the way
that you should act and what should the
values be?
Now there's an old mythological idea
that the gods fight in heaven to see who
is the dominant God.
While you can imagine all of these
individual tribes,
they had their ideals and those were
creatures of their imagination,
but those were imagined representations
of proper behavioral patterns and they
saw there was this transcendent 10 super
ordinate and so then try bay would come
into contact with tried b be and the
guards would clash and out of that,
and I know the death and destruction
that went with it.
The two tribes would integrate and maybe
that would take hundreds of years and
the religious system that sat above
that,
which was the representation of the
dominance hierarchy,
would also transform.
So you take [inaudible] Bay and you take
try b and then you'd take tried c and
then you paid try b and they all
accumulate across time and,
and,
and sort out and articulate and
represent all of their beliefs.
And what happens is that this tribe has
a game and this tribe has a game and
this tribe has a game.
And then if you put all those games
together,
they tilt so that a metagame emerges out
of it.
It's,
it's like if it's,
if it's fortunate,
the best of all three games gets put
together in a larger game and it,
it has to be the best because otherwise
it won't work.
The thing will fall apart,
right?
Because if,
if,
if your family unit isn't functional,
it'll disperse,
you know,
and,
and maybe people will die because of it.
It has to have the,
it has to be iterative,
it has to be playable across time
without falling apart from internal
pressure and without getting wiped notes
from the outside.
So it's very tightly constrained.
So then let's say this happens over tens
of thousands of years,
we could say,
well,
it happened in the Middle East because
we know that as Mesopotamia came
together,
for example,
it was the aggregation of multiple
tribes and all of the Gods of those
tribes.
And we know the Mesopotamians organized
all those gods into one God,
his name was Marduk.
And that the story that they tell about
the aggregation of the gods into one is
the story of the gods getting together
and voting on which of them should be at
the talk.
And then we know that the Mesopotamian
emperor was charged with the
responsibility of acting out that taught
gone and that that's what made him a
good emperor,
and he got reminded of that every year
at the new year ceremony,
he had to tell all the ways that he
hadn't been a good Marduk and then he'd
get punished for it,
and then they would reenact the battle
of the gods and recreate this martech
character.
Okay,
so,
so you can understand how that might've
come about.
Now you could say that the idea of that
emergent ideal that was not,
that wasn't rational,
it was the consequence of conflict and
cooperation in,
in the real world across time.
The representations of that were,
you know,
we might think about them as narrative
representations or if they're deep
enough,
even as an anthology,
you could think about those as the,
as the soil for which religious
presuppositions emerge.
And so what happens is that what you
have at the top of the dominance
hierarchy as your representation of the
good person is no different in its
totality.
Then the idea of the sovereign God that
has emerged across thousands and
thousands of years of human history,
so the whole structure has this thing at
the top and it's regarded in imagination
as divine.
It's the consequence of the represent
the consequence of the battle of
representations,
of morality in imagination across
thousands and thousands of years,
and that's a reflection of the actual
conflict and restructuring of society is
across all that time.
So then you have this thing at the top,
so we could say in the West,
in western Europe,
that thing at the top is Christ and
that's the dying and the dying and dying
and revivifying hero.
We talked about reasons for that.
That's the thing that can go to the
underworld and then come back up.
Okay,
that's at the top.
What happens when it disappears?
What will turn to Dostoevsky for that?
This is from notes from underground,
so this is someone who's in the
underground and that's where you go when
your value systems collapsed.
I'm a sick man.
I'm a spiteful man.
I'm an unattractive man.
I believe my liver is diseased.
However,
I know nothing at all about my disease
and do not know for certain what ails
me.
I don't consult a doctor for it and
never have I ever respect her medicine
than doctors.
Besides I'm extremely superstitious
sufficiently,
so to respect medicine.
Anyway,
I am well educated enough not to be
superstitious,
but.
But I am superstitious.
No,
I refuse to consult a doctor from spike
that you will probably not understand.
Well,
I understand that though.
Of course I can't explain who it is,
precisely that I'm more declining in
this case.
By my spite.
I'm perfectly well aware that I cannot
pay out the doctors and extract revenge
by not consulting them.
I know better than anyone that by all
this I'm only injuring myself and no one
else,
but still,
if I don't consult a doctor,
it's from spiked.
My liver is bad.
Well,
let it get worse.
Now he's a civil servant.
I low ranting civil servant and he's
retired because he got a little bit of
inheritance.
He says,
when petitioners used to come for
information to the table at which I sat,
I used to grind my teeth at them and I
felt intense enjoyment when I succeeded
in making anybody unhappy,
I almost always succeeded.
For the most part.
They were all timid people.
Of course they were petitioners,
but you know,
gentlemen,
what was the chief point about my spite?
Well,
the whole point that the real standard
lay it in the fact that continually even
in the moment of the acute spleen,
I was inwardly conscious with shame,
that I was not only not spiteful,
but not even embittered and that I was
simply scaring sparrows at random and
amusing myself by it.
I was lying when I just said,
now that I was a spiteful officials,
I was lying from spike.
I was simply amusing myself with the
petitioners and with the officer and in
reality,
I never could become spiteful.
I was conscious every moment in myself
of many very many elements,
absolutely opposite to that.
I felt them positively swarming in me
these opposite elements.
I knew that they had been swarming and
me my whole life and craving some outlet
for me,
but I would not let them out,
would not let them purposely,
purposely would not let them out.
He tormented me until I was ashamed.
They drove me to convulsions and sick
and be at last.
At last.
How are they sick and me now.
You're not fencing gentleman that I'm
expressing remorse for something.
Now that I'm asking your forgiveness for
something,
I'm sure you're fancying that however I
assure you I do not care if you are.
It was not only that I could not become
a spiteful.
I did not know how to become anything,
neither spiteful nor kind.
Neither a rascal nor and honest man.
Neither hero nor an insect.
Now I'm living my life out in my corner,
taunting myself with the spike lists and
useless constellation that an
intelligent man cannot become anything
seriously,
and it's only the fool who becomes
anything.
A direct person I regard as the real
normal man
as his tender mother.
Nature wished to see him once she
graciously brought them into being on
the earth.
I not such a man til I'm green in the
face,
he's stupid.
I'm not disputing that,
but perhaps the normal man should be
stupid.
How do you know?
Perhaps it's very beautiful in fact,
and I am the more persuaded of that
suspicion if one can call it so by the
fact that you take,
for instance the antithesis of the
normal man that is the man of acute
selfconsciousness who has come,
of course not out of the lap of nature,
but out of a retort.
This is also almost mysticism gentlemen,
but I suspect this to miss retort made,
man is sometimes so nonplussed in the
presence of his intense USCIS,
the normal man that with all his
exaggerated self consciousness,
he genuinely thinks himself a mouse and
automation at all.
It may be an acutely conscious mouse,
yet it is a mouse.
Well,
the other is a man and therefore etc.
Etc.
And thE worst of it is he himself,
his very own self looks on himself as a
mouse.
No one asks him to do so.
And that's an important point.
Now,
let us look at this mouse in action.
Let us suppose for existence,
for instance,
that it feels insulted and it almost
always feels insulted and it wants to
revenge itself too.
There mAy even be a greater of a
cumulation of spike in it than in the
man of nature and truth,
the base and nasty desire to vent that
spite on it's a sale.
Assailant rankles,
perhaps even more nastily in it than in
the man of nature and truth for throw
these innate stupidity,
the latter.
The normal mac looks upon his revenge.
Is justice pure and simple?
Well in consequences,
his acute selfconsciousness the mouse
does not believe in any justice at all.
To come at last to the deed itself to
the very act of revenge apart from one
the one fundamental nastiness.
The luck was mouse succeeds in creating
around it.
So many other nastiness is in the form
of doubts and questions adds to the one
question.
So many unsettled questions that there
are inevitably works around it,
up around it,
a sort of fatal brute,
a stinking mess made up of it's doubts.
Emotions,
end of the content spat upon it by the
direct men of action who stands solemnly
about it as judges and arbitrators
laughing at it until they're healthy,
sides ache.
Of course,
the only thing left for is to dismiss
all that with a wave of it's paul and
with a smile of assumed contempt in
which it does not even itself believe
and creep ignominiously into its
mousehole there and it's nasty.
Stinking underground.
Home are insulted,
crushed and ridiculed.
Mouse promptly becomes absorbed in cold,
malignant and above all everlasting
spite for 40 years together,
it will remember it's injury down to the
smallest most ignominious details,
and every time we'll add up itself
detail still more in ignominious,
spitefully,
teasing and turmeric itself with its own
imagination.
It will be ashamed of it's imaginings,
yet it will recall it all.
It will go over and over every detail.
It will invent unheard of things against
itself,
pretending that those things might have
happened and will forgive nothing.
Maybe it will begin to revenge itself
too,
but as it were piece meal in trivial
ways from behind the stove incognito,
without believing either in its own
right to vengeance or in the success of
its revenge.
knowing that from all its efforts at
revenge,
it will suffer a hundred times more than
he on whom it revenge itself.
While he I dare say,
well not even scratch itself on its
deathbed,
it will recall it all over again.
With interest accumulated over all the
years now.
The idea that nietzsche dostoevsky were
developing was that
the dawning of consciousness in western
society of the mythological substructure
of the value system and the
impossibility of conceptualizing that or
proving the validity of it's structured
from scientific means doomed it to do
the people who were encapsulated in that
system to formal disbelief in it and
what they concluded from that was
exactly what dos dsd,
just stripe,
which is that someone with that level of
acute consciousness and cultural self
knowledge would immediately come become
fragmented beyond belief,
unable to act,
unhappy,
resentful and dangerous,
and both osteous in nature and in their
works and dostoevsky developed this idea
most particularly in a novel called the
devil's said,
that once that you had got to that
point,
which was inevitable if you were smart
enough to take seriously what was going
on.
It was oNly a tiny step to
identification with a murderer city
ology.
Now,
some of the existentialists started to
work up what you might regard as a
solution to this problem,
and I'm going to read character guards
solution.
It is now cure.
ChAracter guard was a danish existential
philosopher and he lived earlier the
niche and he was,
in some sense,
you might think about him as the first
modern psychologist he was.
He was the first person to
conceptualize,
for example,
of the separate entity of anxiety and
despair.
It is now about four years ago that I
got the notion of wanting to try my luck
as an author.
I remember it quite clearly.
That was on a sunday.
Yes,
that's it.
It's sunday afternoon.
I was seated as usual out of doors at
the cafe in the fredericksburg garden.
I'd been a student for half a score of
years,
although never lazy.
All my activity nevertheless was like a
glittering inactivity.
I kind of occupation for which I still
have a great partiality and for which I
perhaps even have a little genius.
I read much spent the remainder of the
day idling and thinking our or thinking
and idling,
but that was all it came to,
so I sat there and smoke my cigar until
I lapsed into thought among other
thoughts.
I remember these you are goiNg on.
I said to myself to become an old man
without being anything and without
really undertaking to do anything on the
other hand,
wherever you look around you in life and
in literature,
you see the celebrated names and
figures,
the precious and much heralded men who
were coming into prominence and who are
much talked about the many benefactors
of the age who know how to benefit
mankind by making life easier and
easier,
some by railways,
others by omnibuses and steamboats,
others by telegraph,
others by easily apprehended
compendiums,
short and recitals of everything worth
knowing,
and finally the true benefactors of the
age who make spiritual existence easier
and easier,
yet more and more significant,
and what are you doing here?
My soliloquy,
it was interrupted for my cigar with
smoked out and a new one had to be lit
so I smoked again and then suddenly this
thought flashed through my mind.
You must do something,
but in as much with your Limited
capacities,
it will be impossible to make anything
easier than it has become.
You must with the same humanitarian
enthusiasm as the others undertake to
make something harder.
This notion pleased me immensely and at
the same time it flattered me to think
that I like the rest of them would be
loved and esteemed by the whole
community,
for when all combined in every way to
make everything easier,
there remains only one possible danger,
namely that the eas becomes so great
that it becomes altogether too great.
Then there is only one want left,
though it is not yet felt want,
when people will want difficulty out of
love for mankind and out of disparate my
embarrassing situation,
seeing that I had accomplished nothing
and was unable to make anything easier
than it already was,
and moved by a genuine interest in those
who make everything easy.
I can see that as my task to create
difficulties everywhere.
Same idea in different words,
a traveler.
This is nature and this is part of the
development of his answer to the
conundrum that he rates a traveler would
seen many countries and peoples and
several continents was asked what human
traits he had found everywhere and he
answered.
Men are inclined to laziness.
Some will feel that he might've said
with greater justice,
they are all timid.
They hide behind customs and opinions at
bottom.
However,
every human being knows very well that
he is in this world just once as
something unique and no accident,
however strange we'll throw together a
second time into a unity such a curious
and diffuse plurality.
He knows it,
but he hides it like a bad conscience.
Why procurer of his neighbor who insists
on convention and veils himself with it,
but what is it that compels the
individual human being to fear his
neighbor and to think and act heard
fashion and not to be glad of himself a
sense of shame perhaps in a few rare
cases in the vast majority,
it's the desire for comfort and inertia.
In short,
that inclination to laziness of which
the traveler spoke,
he's right.
Men are even lazier than they are
timorous,
and what they fear most is the troubles
with which any unconditional honesty and
nudity would burden them.
Only artists hate this slovenly life in
borrowed manners and loosely fitting
opinions and unveiled the secret.
Everybody's bad conscience.
The principle that every human being is
a unique wonder.
They dared to show us the human being as
he is down to the last muscle himself
and himself alone.
Even more that in this rigorous
consistency of his uniqueness,
he is beautiful and worth contemplating
as novel and as incredible as any work
of nature,
and by no means dope.
When a great thinker despises man,
it's their laziness that he despises for
it is on account of this,
that they have the appearance of factory
products and seem indifferent and
unworthy of companionship or
instruction.
The human being who does not wish to
belong to the mass materially seats must
merely cease being comfortable with
himself.
Let him follow his conscience,
which shouts at him.
Be yourself.
What you are at present,
doing,
opining,
and desiring.
That's not really you.
That's nietzsche and dostoevsky and
existentialism in.
That's the bare beginning of the thing.